[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 el fascismo fue creado hace 100 años
en italia por benito mussolini se
extendió durante el siglo 20 por europa
y también llegó a américa fue derrotado
pero la tentación fascista nunca está
muy lejos algunos líderes del siglo 21
se les ha llamado fascistas pero que
tienen de fascistas los populismos
actuales para respondernos hoy hace
escala en parís federico finchelstein
que es historiador argentino y profesor
de la new school for social research de
nueva york'
federico muchísimas gracias por estar
con nosotros conectado desde eeuu desde
nueva york
sí muchas gracias a ustedes un gusto
estar en el programa en su último libro
breve historia de la mentira fascista
publicado en febrero por la editorial
taurus sostiene que los líderes
populistas del siglo 21 toman prestado
del del fascismo herramientas como
cuestionar la realidad promover la
paranoia y también la violencia o
difundir mentiras en el ex presidente de
eeuu donald trump o el mandatario de
brasil
bolsonaro son fascistas
bueno están muy cerca presentan lo que
yo los entiendo como un gran peligro de
fascismo es decir para pensar sobre todo
la diferencia entre fascismo y populismo
lo que tenemos que pensar es que el
populismo en el poder si bien existió
antes incluso a fines del siglo 19 el
populismo en el poder como régimen
político se constituye como tal en luego
de la derrota de los fascismos en 1945 y
se reformula es decir los populistas
eran dictadores y fascistas que intentan
arroparse y reformularse en clave
democrática y en ese sentido gente como
perón en argentina o borregas o en
brasil dejan cuatro elementos centrales
del fascismo es decir dejan de lado la
dictadura dejan de lado esa mentira
diría absoluta este es un tema sobre el
que con mucho gusto podemos volver dejan
de lado la militarización de la política
y la violencia y dejan de lado
este el racismo como eje central de la
política en ese sentido los populistas
digamos de perón a berlusconi o de de
vargas en brasil a chávez en venezuela
no se van a distinguir por estos cuatro
elementos van a ser autoritarios pero en
democracia van a ser votados y van a
hacer esa mezcla tan típicamente
populista entre democracia y
autoritarismo ahora con los nuevos
populismo del siglo del siglo 21 gente
como tram bolsonaro box en españa hay
albín en italia
orbán en hungría y en arena modelo en la
india lo que surge es justamente un
populismo que se acerca a esos elementos
que los populistas habían dejado detrás
entonces lo que vemos es un populismo
que se parece cada vez más al fascismo
porque justamente vuelve a presentar al
racismo la xenofobia el odio la
discriminación como eje central de la
política vuelve a la violencia y la
militarización de la política vuelve
vuelve sobre todo a esa forma de mentir
de negar la realidad e incluso aún peor
de convertir o tratar de convertir la
realidad de accord
y transformar la realidad para que se
parezca a la mentira que es más bien
típica del fascismo y del vino del
populismo en ese marco lo que vemos es
justamente unos populismos que cada vez
parecen más fascistas y menos populistas
mucha gente que vota estos políticos
populistas ya no creen en los medios de
comunicación tradicionales desconfían
del sistema político y adhieren a tesis
complotistas una de las características
de donald trump era por ejemplo
arremeter contra los medios de
comunicación y decir que todo lo que se
decía sobre él era una face news en qué
medida son responsables los políticos de
fomentar caos como hemos visto en enero
en el asalto a al capitolio que la gente
adhiera a tesis complotistas y ya no se
crea no a los medios tradicionales es un
poco peligroso
es terrible es muy peligroso y
justamente cuando yo hablaba de estos
cuatro elementos típicamente fascistas
violencia racismo
mentiras y dictaduras este es el
elemento faltante y con los eventos del
6 de enero justamente lo que trampa
intenta es un golpe de estado yo lo
había incluso escrito
en un mes y pico antes en el washington
post advirtiendo justamente por lo que
conocemos de la historia latinoamericana
y de otras historias que lo que parecía
encaminarse lo que parecía que trampa
estaba planeando en un golpe de estado
basado justamente en esa gran mentira al
estilo fascista de que había ganado la
elección cuando en realidad no lo había
ganado entonces ahí vemos justamente esa
vuelta a los cuatro elementos ya no sólo
violencia racismo
y mentiras sino también dictadura eso es
lo que hubiera pasado en eeuu si la
democracia no hubiera triunfado
derrotando esa gran mentira de trans
porque el odio entonces a los medios
porque justamente la función de los
medios en democracia es darnos al resto
de los ciudadanos darnos a los
ciudadanos
hechos básicamente brindarnos elementos
de esa realidad empírica para poder
nosotros tomar decisiones interpretar
votar
y pensar esto es justamente lo que estos
fascistas y estos populistas que quieren
ser fascistas como el caso de trump o
bolsonaro es justamente un problema para
ellos no quieren que pensemos y quieren
justamente que no se distinga entre lo
que en términos que van a decirlo en
términos concretos propaganda y la
realidad observable por eso justamente
en mi libro sobre la mentira fascista yo
empiezo digamos en el epígrafe en el
epígrafe aparece una frase orwelliana
fascista prácticamente trans que dice
que le dice a sus seguidores
no crean en lo que están viendo cómo
puede ser cómo puede ser que se nos pida
que no neguemos la realidad que nuestros
ojos observan y esto sí esto es muy
cercano al fascismo y es peligrosísimo
lo mismo vemos en españa' con box que
por suerte no está en el gobierno y lo
vemos lo mismo vemos en italia y en
muchos otros lugares del mundo esto es
un peligro yo diría más bien global no
está facilitación de la realidad qué
responsabilidad tienen los partidos de
izquierdas los partidos progresistas en
este auge de este populismo tan
peligroso que estamos viendo porque
muchos de los electores de estos líderes
populistas son de clase trabajadora
que en tiempos pasados
habían votado a partidos de izquierda e
incluso en el caso de francia al partido
comunista y vemos que muchos de esos
electores se han ido a votar a la
ultraderechista marine lepén en qué
medida son responsables los partidos de
izquierdas en ese auge yo creo que la
responsabilidad de los políticos es muy
importante porque justamente digamos
este tipo de política xenófoba que ya
hace mucho tiempo los socialdemócratas
alemanes habían definido creo que muy
muy acertadamente como el socialismo de
los imbéciles es decir en vez de
prometerles un cambio en las condiciones
de vida a sus votantes les prometen odio
y les prometen una explicación simple
decir que todos sus problemas son culpa
de los extranjeros o de la gente que
piensa o luce distinto
en ese marco justamente yo creo que un
límite digamos o más bien un aliciente
para este tipo de líderes están
están basados en el odio y en el
extremismo es justamente que la
democracia no se realice en tanto
posibilidades de igualdad
y de que la gente se siente realmente
representada por sus políticos es decir
si no mejoran las condiciones de
representación y no mejoran las
condiciones y no se combate la
desigualdad económica política cultural
evidentemente esto esto habrá el terreno
para este tipo de políticos yo creo por
otra parte que también una gran
responsabilidad es la de los partidos de
centro o incluso centroderecha que
muchas veces
aceptan los argumentos de esta gente e
incluso los llevan a cabo entonces lo
que vemos es por ejemplo con el caso
francés políticos de centroderecha que
este para tratar de sacarle votos a esa
derecha extrema e incorporan argumentos
xenófobos a sus propias políticas y esto
se ha demostrado que en general es si
digamos si sigue a los votantes se les
ofrece no justamente una política
igualitaria en contraposición al odio
sino más bien un odio like los votantes
muchas veces eligen el odio extremo no
hay fascismo de izquierda
no el fachismo es por definición de
extrema derecha el fascismo es anti
izquierda justamente como había ya ha
estudiado hace muchísimo tiempo ahora se
hace un tiempo el gran historiador del
fascismo zeev sternhell lo que él decía
justamente es que el fascismo logre
incorporar retórica de izquierda o
retórica social a lo que es un programa
en realidad de gran exclusión y
discriminación y odio entonces por eso
el nombre el nombre que también se basa
en una gran mentira que de los nazis que
es nacionalsocialismo decir no había
nada de socialismo en el nazismo
justamente era un repudio de la igualdad
un repudio de los derechos sociales que
muchas veces representaba la
socialdemocracia entonces en general
esto forma parte del repertorio de
mentiras de estos de estos fascistas o
de estos aspirantes a fascistas que
justamente definen definir al navío como
el fascismo cuando los fascistas son
ellos y otra de las características del
fascismo es la falta total de libertad y
de pensamiento llevamos ya unos años en
los que se está censurando el arte y la
literatura por machista
racistas se han cambiado títulos por
ejemplo los diez negritos de agatha
christie ahora se llaman eran diez aquí
en francia usted considera que lo
políticamente correcto puede degenerar
en una suerte de fascismo
a mí me parece que no porque el fascismo
es una experiencia de extrema derecha
racista xenófoba ecuatorial que que es
muy específica es decir reúne
características que los historiadores
del fascismo hemos estudiado y definido
en ese sentido me parece que no se debe
confundir fascismo con perspectivas
autoritarias y discriminatorias de la
misma forma que no hay fascismo sin
dictadura muchas dictaduras pueden ser
dictaduras sin ser fascistas y lo mismo
pasa con actitudes como decir ese
homofóbicas o excluyentes por parte de
otro tipo de ideologías es decir no el
fascismo no es sino todo autoritarismo
es fascista no hemos vistos
manifestaciones por ejemplo cosas
absurdas
en el 8 de marzo en el día internacional
de la mujer en parís en la plaza de la
republica un grupo de antifascistas
atacó a feministas llamando las
fascistas un grupo que está a favor de
la prostitución del velo islámico y de
la causa
francés es una escena bastante absurda
el debate de las ideas ha muerto el
fascista siempre es el otro
bueno lamentablemente como como yo
analizo en mi trabajo hay un abuso del
término fácil es decir el fascismo
muchas veces es utilizado como un
insulto y no como una ideología
justamente como decía yo de extrema
derecha dictatorial con elementos y
objetivos específicos es decir no todo
autoritarismo no toda violencia es
fascista por otra parte no hay fascismo
sin esa violencia y sin ese
autoritarismo y discriminación etcétera
no pero bueno ese es un término que se
ha abusado justamente porque se presenta
como insulto y por eso la necesidad de
estudiarlo históricamente pues
muchísimas gracias federico finchelstein
historiador argentino experto en
fascismo y profesor de la new school of
social research de nueva york por esta
entrevista muchísimas gracias muchas
veces y muchísimas gracias a todos
ustedes ya saben que nos pueden
acompañar por internet en rf y mundo.com
bien france24 punto com hasta pronto
amigos
[Música]